The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today is our
third and probably final lecture
on approximation algorithms.
We're going to take
a different approach
to proving inapproximability
to optimization problems called
gap problems.
And we'll think about
gap-preserving reductions.
We will prove along the way
optimal lower bound on MAX-3SAT
and other fun things.
So let's start with
what a gap problem is.
I haven't actually seen a
generic definition of this,
so this is new terminology,
but I think helpful.
A gap problem is a way of
converting an optimization
problem into a decision problem.
Now, we already know
one way to do that.
If you have an NPO
optimization problem,
you convert it into the
obvious decision problem,
which is OPT at most k.
For the minimization
problem, that is NP-complete.
But we want to get something
useful from an approximability
standpoint.
And so the idea is, here's
a different problem.
Instead of just deciding
whether OPT is at most k,
we want to distinguish
between OPT being at most k
versus OPT being at least
k over c for some value c.
And the analogy here is with
c approximation algorithm,
c does not have to be
constant, despite the name.
Could be a function of n.
Maybe it's log n.
Maybe it's n to the
epsilon, whatever.
So for a minimization
problem, normally--
did I get this the right way?
Sorry, that should be c times k.
For minimization and
for maximization,
it's going to be the reverse.
And I think I'm going to use
strict inequality here also.
So a minimization.
There's a gap here
between k and c times k.
We're imagining here
c is bigger than 1.
So distinguishing
between being less than k
and being at least c
times k leaves a hole.
And the point is you
are promised that
your input-- you
have a question?
AUDIENCE: The second one,
should it really be c over k?
PROFESSOR: Sorry, no.
Thank you.
C and k sound the same, so it's
always easy to mix them up.
Cool.
So the idea is that
you're-- so in both cases,
there's a ratio gap here of c.
And the idea is
that you're promised
that your input falls into
one of these two categories.
What does it mean
to distinguish--
I mean, I tell you up
front the input either
has this property
or this property,
and I want you to
decide which one it is.
And we'll call
these yes instances
and these no instances.
Normally with a
decision problem,
the no instance is that OPT is
just one bigger or one smaller.
Now we have a big gap between
the no instances and the yes
instances.
We're told that that's true.
This is called promise problem.
And effectively
what that means is
if you're trying to come
up with an algorithm
to solve this
decision problem, you
don't care what the
algorithm does if OPT
happens to fall in between.
The algorithm can
do whatever it want.
It can output digits
of pi in the middle,
as long as when OPT is it
at most k or greater than
or equal to k, it outputs yes.
And when OPT is at least a
factor of c away from that,
it outputs no.
So that's an easier problem.
And the cool thing is if the
c gap version of a problem
is NP-hard, then so
is c approximating
the original problem.
So this really is in direct
analogy to c approximation.
And so this lets us think
about an NP hardness
for a decision problem and prove
an inapproximability result.
This is nice because in
the last two lectures,
we were having to keep track
of a lot more in just defining
what inapproximability meant
and APX hardness and so on.
Here it's kind of back
to regular NP hardnes.
Now, the techniques
are completely
different in this world than
our older NP hardness proofs.
But still, it's kind of
comforting to be back
in decision land.
Cool.
So because of this implication,
in previous lectures
we were just worried about
proving inapproximability.
But today we're
going to be thinking
about proving that gap
problems are NP-hard,
or some other kind of hardness.
This is a stronger
type of result.
So in general,
inapproximability is
kind of what you care about
from the algorithmic standpoint,
but gap results saying
that hey, your problem
is hard even if you have
this huge gap between the yes
instances and the
no instances, that's
also of independent
interest, more
about the structure
of the problem.
But one implies the other.
So this is the stronger
type of thing to go for.
The practical reason to
care about this stuff
is that this gap idea lets you
get stronger inapproximability
results.
The factor c you get by
thinking about gaps in practice
seems to be larger
than the gaps you
get by L reductions and things.
So let me tell you about one
other type of gap problem.
This is a standard one, a
little bit more precise.
Consider MAX-SAT.
Pick your favorite
version of MAX-SAT,
or MAX-CSP was the
general form where you
could have any type of clause.
Instead of just a c gap, we will
define slightly more precisely
an a, b gap, which is to
distinguish between OPT
is less than a times
the number of clauses,
and OPT is at least b times
the number of clauses.
So whereas here everything
was relative to some input k
that you want to
decide about, with SAT
there's a kind of absolute
notion of what you'd
like to achieve, which is
that you satisfy everything,
all clauses are true.
So typically we'll
think about b being one.
And so you're distinguishing
between a satisfiable instance
where all clauses are
satisfied, and something
that's very unsatisfiable.
There's some kind of usually
constant fraction unsatisfiable
clauses.
We need this level
of precision thinking
about when you're right
up against 100% satisfied
versus 1% satisfied or something
like that, or 1% satisfiable.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Do you use the same
notation for one [INAUDIBLE]
or only for-- so the one problem
like the maximum number of ones
you can get.
PROFESSOR: I haven't
seen it, but yeah, that's
a good question.
Certainly valid to do
it for-- we will see it
for one other type of problem.
For any problem, if you can
define some absolute notion
of how much you'd
like to get, you
can always measure relative to
that and define this kind of a,
b gap problem.
Cool.
All right.
So how do we get these gaps?
There's two, well maybe
three ways, I guess.
In general, we're going to
use reductions, like always.
And you could start from
no gap and make a gap,
or start from a
gap of additive one
and turn it into a big
multiplicative gap.
That will be
gap-producing reductions.
You could start with some
gap and then make it bigger.
That's gap-amplifying reduction.
Or you could just start with
a gap and try to preserve it.
That would be
gap-preserving reductions.
In general, once
you have some gap,
you try to keep it or make
it bigger to get stronger
hardness for your problem.
So the idea with a
gap-producing reduction
is that you have no assumption
about your starting problem.
In general, reduction we're
going from some problem
a to some problem b.
And what we would like is that
the output instance to problem
b, the output of the
reduction has OPT equal to k
or, for a minimization problem,
OPT bigger than c times k.
And for a maximization problem,
OPT less than k over c.
So that's just saying we
have a gap in the output.
We assume nothing about
the input instance.
That would be a
gap-producing production.
Now we have seen some of
these before, or at least
mentioned them.
One of them, this is
from lecture three,
I think for Tetris.
We proved NP hardness, which was
this three partition reduction.
And the idea is that if you
could satisfy that and open
this thing, then you could get
a zillion points down here.
In most of the
instances down here,
we squeeze this down to
like an n to the epsilon.
That's still hard.
And so n to the 1 minus epsilon
of the instances down here,
and you're given a ton of
pieces to fill in the space,
get lots of points.
If the answer was no here, then
you won't get those points.
And so OPT is very small, at
most, say, n to the epsilon.
If you can solve
this instance, we
have a yes instance in the
input, then we get end points.
So the gap there is n
to the 1 minus epsilon.
So the Tetris reduction, we
assume nothing about the three
partition instance.
It was just yes or no.
And we produced an instance
that had a gap of n
to the 1 minus epsilon.
We could set epsilon
to any constant
we want bigger than zero.
We also mentioned
another such reduction.
And in general, for a
lot of games and puzzles,
you can do this.
It's sort of on all
or nothing deal.
And gap-producing reduction
is a way to formalize that.
Another problem we talked
about last class I believe
was non-metric TSP.
I just give you
a complete graph.
Every edge has some number on it
that's the length of that edge.
You want to find a TSP tour
of minimum total length.
This is really hard to
approximate because depending
on your model, you can use
let's say edge weights.
And to be really annoying
would be 0, comma 1.
And if I'm given a
Hamiltonicity instance, wherever
there's an edge, I
put a weight of zero.
Wherever there's not an
edge, I put a weight of one.
And then if the input
graph was Hamiltonian,
it's a yes instance.
Then the output thing will
have a tour of length zero.
And if the input
was not Hamiltonian,
then the output
will have weight n.
Ratio between n and
zero is infinity.
So this is an
infinite gap creation
if you allow weights of zero.
If you say zero
is cheating, which
we did and some papers
do, you could instead
do one and infinity, where
infinity is the largest
representable number.
So that's going to be
something like 2 to the n
if you allow usual binary
encodings of numbers.
If you don't, the
PB case, then that
would be n to some constant.
But you get a big
gap in any case.
So you get some gap equals huge.
So these are kind of trivial
senses of inapproximability,
but hey, that's
one way to do it.
What we're going
to talk about today
are other known ways to get
gap production that are really
cool and more broadly useful.
This is useful when you have a
sort of all or nothing problem.
A lot of the time,
it's not so clear.
There's a constant
factor approximation.
So some giant gap like this
isn't going to be possible,
but still gaps are possible.
Now, an important part of the
story here is the PCP theorem.
So this is not about drugs.
This is about another
complexity class.
And the complexity
class is normally
written PCP of order
log n, comma order one.
I'm going to simplify this
to just PCP as the class.
The other notions
make sense here,
although the parameters don't
turn out to matter too much.
And it's rather lengthy
to write that every time.
So I'm just going to write PCP.
Let me first tell you what
this class is about briefly,
and then we'll see why
it's directly related
to gap problems,
hence where a lot
of these gap-producing
reductions come from.
So PCP stands for
Probabilistically Checkable
Proof.
The checkable
proof refers to NP.
Every yes instance
has a checkable proof
that the answer is yes.
Probabilistically
checkable means
you can check it even faster
with high probability.
So normally to check a proof,
we take polynomial time in NP.
Here we want to
achieve constant time.
That's the main idea.
That can't be done perfectly,
but you can do it correctly
with high probability.
So in general, a
problem in PCP has
certificates of polynomial
length, just like NP.
And we have an algorithm for
checking certificates, which
is given certificate,
and it's given order log
n bits of randomness.
That's what this first
parameter refers to,
is how much randomness
the algorithm's given.
So we restrict the
amount of randomness
to a very small amount.
And it should tell you
whether the instance
is a yes instance
or a no instance,
in some sense if you're
given the right certificate.
So in particular,
if the instance
was a yes instance-- so this
is back to decision problems,
just like NP.
There's no optimization here.
But we're going to apply
this to gap problems,
and that will relate
us to optimization.
So let's say there's no error
on yes instances, although you
could relax that.
It won't make a big difference.
So if you have a yes instance,
and you give the right
certificate-- so this is
for some certificate--
the algorithm's
guaranteed to say yes.
So no error there.
Where we add some slack is
if there's a no instance.
Now normally in NP
for a no instance,
there is no correct certificate.
Now, the algorithm
will sometimes
say yes even if we give
it the wrong certificate.
There is no right certificate.
But it will say so with some
at most constant probability.
So let's say the probability
that the algorithm says
no is at least some constant,
presumably less than one.
If it's one, then that's NP.
If it's a half,
that would be fine.
A tenth, a hundredth,
they'll all be the same.
Because once you have
such an algorithm that
achieves some
constant probability,
you could apply it log
1 over epsilon times.
And we reduce the
error to epsilon.
The probability of error goes
to epsilon if we just repeat
this log 1 over epsilon times.
So in constant
time-- it didn't say.
The order one here refers to the
running time of the algorithm.
So this is an order
one time algorithm.
So the point is, the
algorithm's super fast
and still in constant
time for constant epsilon.
You can get arbitrarily
small error probability,
say one in 100 or
one in a million,
and it's still pretty good.
And you're checking your
proof super, super fast.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Why is there a
limit on the randomness?
PROFESSOR: This
limit on randomness
is not strictly necessary.
For example, n
bits of randomness
turned out not to help you.
That was proved later.
But we're going to
use this in a moment.
It will help us simulate this
algorithm without randomness,
basically.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If the verifier
runs in constant time,
can it either read
or was written?
PROFESSOR: So this is constant
time in a model of computation
where you can read log
n bits in one step.
So your word, let's
say, is log n bits long.
So you have enough time
to read the randomness.
Obviously you don't have
time to read the certificate,
because that has
polynomial length.
But yeah, constant time.
Cool.
Other questions?
So that is the
definition of PCP.
Now let me relate
it to gap problems.
So let's say first claim is
that if we look at this gap sap
problem, where b equals one and
a is some constant, presumably
less than one, then-- in fact,
that should be less than one.
Why did I write strictly
less than 1 here?
This is a constant
less than one.
Then I claim that
problem is in PCP,
that there is a
probabilistically checkable
proof for this instance.
Namely, it's a satisfying
variable assignment.
Again, this instance
either has the prop--
when in a yes instance
all of the entire thing
is satisfiable.
So just like before, I
can have a certificate,
just like an NP satisfying
assignment to the variables
is good.
In the no instance, now I
know, let's say, at most half
of the things are satisfied
if this is one half.
And so what is my
algorithm going to do?
In order to get some at
most constant probability
of failure, it's going
to choose a random clause
and check that it was satisfied.
Uniform random.
So I've got log n bits.
Let's say there are n clauses.
So I can choose one of them at
random by flipping log n coins.
And then check so that
involves-- this is three SATs.
It only involves
three variables.
I check those three
variable value assignments
in my certificate by random
access into the certificate.
In constant time, I
determine whether that clause
is satisfied.
If the clause is satisfied,
algorithm returns yes.
Otherwise, return no.
Now, if it was a
satisfying assignment,
the algorithm will
always say yes.
So that's good.
If it was not
satisfiable, we know
that, let's say at most half
of the clauses are satisfiable.
Which means in
every certificate,
the algorithm will say no
at least half the time.
And half is whatever
that constant is.
So that means the probability
that the algorithm
is wrong is less than 1 over
the gap, whatever that ratio is.
Cool?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So does
this [INAUDIBLE]?
So for [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let me tell
you, the PCP theorem
is that NP equals PCP.
This is proved.
So all problems are in PCP.
But this is some motivation
for where this class came from.
I'm not going to
prove this theorem.
The original proof
is super long.
Since then, there have been
relatively short proofs.
I think the shortest proof
currently is two pages long.
Still not going to
prove it because it's
a bit beside the
point to some extent.
It does use reductions
and gap amplification,
but it's technical to
prove it, let's say.
But I will give you some more
motivation for why it's true.
So for example, so
here's one claim.
If one-- let's
change this notation.
If less than 1, comma
1, gap 3SAT is NP-hard,
then NP equals PCP.
So we know that this
is true, but before we
know that here-- so we just
proved that this thing is NPCP.
And if furthermore
this problem--
we're going to prove
this is NP-hard.
That's the motivation.
If you believe
that it's NP-hard,
then we know all problems in
NP can reduce to this thing.
And then that thing is NPCP.
So that tells us that
all problems in NP,
you can convert them into
less than 1, comma 1 gap 3SAT
and then get a PCP
algorithm for them.
So that would be one way
to prove the PCP theorem.
In fact, the reverse
is also true.
And this is sort of more
directly useful to us.
If, let's say, 3SAT is NPCP,
then the gap version of 3SAT
is NP-hard.
This is interesting
because-- this is true
because NP equals PCP, in
particular 3SAT is NPCP.
And so we're going to
be able to conclude,
by a very short argument,
that the gap version of 3SAT
is also NP-hard.
And this proves constant factor
inapproximability of 3SAT.
We will see a tighter
constant in a little bit,
but this will be our
first such bound.
And this is a very
general kind of algorithm.
It's kind of cool.
So PCP is easy for the
gap version of 3SAT.
But suppose there was a
probabilistically checkable
proof for just straight up
3SAT when you're not given
any gap bound, which is true.
It does exist.
So we're going to
use that algorithm.
And we're going to do a
gap-preserving reduction.
The PCP algorithm we're given,
because we're looking at PCP
log n, comma order one,
runs in constant time.
Constant time algorithm
can't do very much.
In particular, I can
write the algorithm
as a constant size formula.
It's really a distribution
over such formulas defined
by the log n and the bits.
But let's say it's a
random variable where
for each possible random choice
is a constant size formula that
evaluates to true or
false, corresponding
to whether the algorithm
says yes or no.
We know we can
convert algorithms
to formulas if they're
a short amount of time.
So we can make
that a CNF formula.
Why not?
3CNF if we want.
My goal is to-- I
want to reduce 3SAT
to the gap version of 3SAT.
Because 3SAT we know is NP-hard.
So if I can reduce it to the
gap version of 3SAT, I'm happy.
Then I know the gap version
of 3SAT is also hard.
So here is my reduction.
So I'm given the 3SAT
formula, and the algorithm
evaluates some formula on
it and the certificate.
What I'm going to do is try
all of the random choices.
Because there's only
log n bits, there's
only polynomially many possible
choices for those bits.
Order log n so it's
n to some constant.
And I want to take this
formula, take the conjunction
over all of those choices.
If the algorithm
always says yes,
then this formula
will be satisfied.
So in the yes instance case,
I get a satisfiable formula.
So yes, complies satisfiable,
100% satisfiable.
That corresponds to this number.
I want it to be 100%
in the yes case.
In the no case, I know
that a constant fraction
of these random
choices give a no.
Meaning, they will
not be satisfied.
For any choice,
any certificate, I
know that a constant
fraction of these terms which
I'm conjuncting will
evaluate to false because
of the definition of PCP.
That's what probability
algorithm saying no means.
So it's a constant fraction
of the terms are false.
The terms are the things
we're conjuncting over.
But each term here is a
constant size CNF formula.
So when I and those together,
I really just get one giant
and of clauses.
Constant fraction larger
than the number of terms.
And if a term is false,
that means at least one
of the clauses is false.
And there's only a constant
number of clauses in each term.
So this means a
constant fraction
of the clauses in that giant
conjunction are also false.
And that is essentially it.
That is my reduction.
So in the yes instance, I get
100% percent satisfiable thing.
In the no instance,
I get some constant
strictly less than
1 satisfiable thing.
Because in any solution,
I get a constant fraction
that turn out to be
false, constant fraction
of the clauses.
Now what the constant is,
you'd have to work out things.
You'd have to know how
big your PCP algorithm is.
But at least we get a
constant lower bound proving--
in particular, proving there's
no P [? task ?] for MAX-3SAT.
This is what you might call
a gap-amplifying reduction,
in the sense we
started with no gap.
The instance of 3SAT was
either true or false.
And we ended up with something
with a significant gap.
So what we're going
to talk about next
is called gap-preserving
reductions.
Maybe before I get there,
what we just showed
is that the PCP
theorem is equivalent.
And in particular, we get
gap problems being NP-hard.
This is why we care about PCPs.
And then in general,
once we have
these kinds of gap
hardness results,
we convert our-- when we're
thinking about reductions
from a to b, because we know
gap implies inapproximability,
we could say, OK, 3SAT
is inapproximable,
and then do, say, an l reduction
from 3SAT to something else.
The something else is
therefore inapproximable also.
That's all good.
But we can also,
instead of thinking
about the inapproximability and
how much carries from a to b,
we can think about
the gap directly.
And this is sort of the main
approach in this lecture
that I'm trying to
demonstrate is by preserving
the gap directly,
a, well you get
new gap bounds and generally
stronger gap bounds.
And then those imply
inapproximability results.
But the gap bounds are stronger
than the inapproximability,
and also they tend to give
larger constant factors
in the inapproximability
results.
So what do we want out of
a gap-preserving reduction?
Let's say we have
an instance x of A.
We convert that into an instance
x prime of some problem B.
We're just going to
think about the OPT of x
versus the OPT of x prime.
And what we want for, let's
say, a minimization problem
is two properties.
One is that the OPT-- if the
OPT of x is at most some k,
then the OPT of x prime
is at most some k prime.
And conversely.
So in general, OPT
may not be preserved.
But let's say it changes
by some prime operation.
So in fact, you can think of k
and k prime as functions of n.
So if I know that OPT of x is
at most some function of n,
then I get that OPT of x prime
is at most some other function
of n.
But there's some known
relation between the two.
What I care about is this gap c.
Should be a c prime here.
So what this is saying is
suppose I had a gap, if I know
that all the solutions
are either less than k
or more than c times
k, I want that to be
preserved for some
possibly other gap c
prime in the new problem.
So this is pretty general,
but this is the sort of thing
we want to preserve.
If we had a gap of c before,
we get some gap c prime after.
If c prime equals c, this would
be a perfectly gap-preserving
reduction.
Maybe we'll lose
some constant factor.
If c prime is
greater than c, this
is called gap amplification.
And gap amplification
is essentially
how the PCP theorem is
shown, by repeatedly
growing the gap until
it's something reasonable.
And if you want to, say, prove
that set cover is log n hard,
it's a similar thing where
you start with a small gap
constant factor, and
then you grow it,
and you show you can grow it
to log n before you run out
of space to write it in
your problem essentially,
before your instance gets
more than polynomial.
Or if you want to prove that
[INAUDIBLE] can't be solved
in better than whatever
n to the 1 minus epsilon,
then a similar trick of
gap amplification works.
Those amplification
arguments are involved,
and so I'm not going
to show them here.
But I will show you an example
of a gap-preserving reduction
next, unless there
are questions.
Cool So I'm going to
reduce a problem which
we have mentioned
before, which is MAX
exactly 3 XOR- and XNOR-SAT.
This is linear equations,
[INAUDIBLE] two,
where every equation
has exactly three terms.
So something like xi XOR xj XOR
xk equals one, or something.
You can also have
negations here.
So I have a bunch of
equations like that.
I'm going to just tell you
a gap bound on this problem,
and then we're going to reduce
it to another problem, namely
MAX-E3-SAT.
So the claim here
is that this problem
is one half plus epsilon,
one minus epsilon, gap
hard for any epsilon.
Which in particular
implies that it
is one half minus
epsilon inapproximable,
unless p equals NP.
But this is of course stronger.
It says if you just
look at instances where
let's say 99% of the equations
are satisfiable versus when
51% are satisfiable, it's
NP-hard to distinguish
between those two.
Why one half here?
Because there is a one
half approximation.
I've kind of mentioned
the general approach
for approximation
algorithms for SAT
is take a random assignment,
variable assignment.
And in this case, because these
statements are about a parity,
if you think of xk
as random, it doesn't
matter what these two are.
50% probability this
will be satisfied.
And so you can always satisfy
at least half of the clauses
because this randomized
algorithm will satisfy half
in expectation.
Therefore, in at least one
instance, it will do so.
But if you allow
randomized approximation,
this is a one half approximation
or a two approximation,
depending on your perspective.
So this is really tight.
That's good news.
And this is essentially a
form of the PCP theorem.
PCP theorem says that
there's some algorithm,
and you can prove that in fact
there is an algorithm that
looks like this.
It's a bunch of linear equations
with three terms per equation.
So let's take that as given.
Now, what I want to
show is a reduction
from that problem to MAX-E3-SAT.
So remember MAX-E3-SAT,
you're given
CNF where every
clause has exactly
three distinct literals.
You want to maximize the
number of satisfied things.
So this is roughly the problem
we were talking about up there.
So first thing
I'm going to do is
I want to reduce this to that.
And this is the reduction.
And the first claim is just
that it's an L-reduction.
So that's something
we're familiar with.
Let's think about it that way.
Then we will think about it
in a gap-preserving sense.
So there are two types of
equations we need to satisfy,
the sort of odd case
or the even case.
Again, each of these
could be negated.
I'm just going to double negate
means unnegated over here.
So each equation is going to
be replaced with exactly four
clauses in the E3-SAT instance.
And the idea is, well, if I want
the parity of them to be odd,
it should be the case that
at least one of them is true.
And if you stare at it
long enough, also when
you put two bars in there, I
don't want exactly two of them
to be true.
That's the parity constraint.
If this is true, all four
of these should be true.
That's the first claim,
just by the parity
of the number of bars.
There's either zero
bars or two bars,
or three positive
or one positive.
That's the two cases.
And in this situation where
I want the parity to be even,
even number of trues, I
have all the even number
of trues cases over here.
Here are two of them even,
and here none of them even.
And again, if this is satisfied,
then all four of those
are satisfied.
Now, if these are not
satisfied, by the same argument
you can show that at least
one of these is violated.
But in fact, just
one will be violated.
So for example, so this
is just a case analysis.
Let's say I set all
of these to be zero,
and so their XOR is
zero and not one.
So if they're all false, then
this will not be satisfied,
but the other three will be.
And in general, because
we have, for example,
xi appearing true and
false in different cases,
you will satisfy
three out of four
on the right when you
don't satisfy on the left.
So the difference is
three versus four.
When these are satisfied, you
satisfy four on the right.
When they're unsatisfied, you
satisfy three on the right.
That's all.
Claiming.
So if the equation
is satisfied, then we
get four in the 3SAT instance.
And if it's unsatisfied, we
turn out to get exactly three.
So I want to prove that
this is an L-reduction.
To prove L-reduction,
we need two things.
One is that the additive gap,
if I solve the 3SAT instance
and convert it back into
a corresponding solution
to MAX-E3 XNOR SAT, which
don't change anything.
The variables are just
what they were before.
That the additive gap
from OPT on the right side
is at most some constant
times the additive gap
on the left side, or vice versa.
In this case, the gap is
exactly preserved because it's
four versus three over here.
It's one versus zero over here.
So additive gap remains one.
And that is called beta, I
think, in L-reduction land.
So this was property
two in the L-reduction.
So the additive error in this
case is exactly preserved.
So there's no scale.
Beta equals one.
If there's some other gap,
if it was five versus three,
then we'd have beta equal two.
Then there was the
other property,
which is you need to show that
you don't blow up OPT too much.
We want the OPT on
the right hand side
to be at most some constant
times OPT on the left hand
side.
This requires a
little bit more care
because we need to make sure
OPT is linear, basically.
We did a lot of these
arguments last lecture.
Because even when you
don't satisfy things,
you still get points.
And the difference between
zero and three is big ratio.
We want that to not
happen too much.
And it doesn't happen
too much because we
know the left hand side OPT is
at least a half of all clauses.
So it's not like there are
very many unsatisfied clauses.
At most, half of
them are unsatisfied
because at least half are
satisfiable in the case of OPT.
So here's the full argument.
In general, OPT for
the 3SAT instance
is going to be four times
all the satisfiable things
plus three times all the
unsatisfiable things.
This is the same thing
as saying the-- sorry.
You take three times
the number of equations.
Every equation gets
three points for free.
And then if you also satisfy
them, you get one more point.
So this is an equation on
those things, the two OPTs.
And we get plus three times
the number of equations.
And because there is a
one half approximation,
we know that number of equations
is at most two times OPT.
Because OPT is at least a
half the number of equations.
And so this thing is overall at
most six plus one seven times
OPT E3 XNOR.
And this is the thing
called alpha in L-reduction.
I wanted to compute
these explicitly
because I want to see how
much inapproximability I get.
Because I started with a
tight inapproximability bound
of one half minus
epsilon being impossible,
whereas one half is possible.
It's tight up to this very tiny
arbitrary additive constant.
And over here, we're
going to lose something.
We know from L-reductions,
if you were inapproximable
before, you get
inapproximability
in this case of MAX-E3-SAT.
E3
So what is the factor?
If you think of-- there's
one simplification
here relative to what
I presented before.
A couple lectures ago, we
always thought about one
plus epsilon approximation,
and how does epsilon change.
And that works really well
for minimization problems.
For a maximization problem,
your approximation factor
is-- an approximation
factor of one
plus epsilon means you are at
least this thing times OPT.
And this thing gets
awkward to work with.
Equivalently, with a
different notion of epsilon,
you could just think of a one
minus epsilon approximation
and how does epsilon change.
And in general, for
maximization problem,
if you have one minus
epsilon approximation
before the L-reduction,
then afterwards you
will have a one minus
epsilon over alpha beta.
So for maximization, we
had one plus epsilon.
And then we got one plus
epsilon over alpha beta.
With the minuses,
it also works out.
That's a cleaner way
to do maximization.
So this was a
maximization problem.
We had over here
epsilon was-- sorry,
different notions of epsilon.
Here we have one half
inapproximability
One half is also known
as one minus one half.
So epsilon here is a half.
And alpha was seven.
Beta was one.
And so we just divide by seven.
So in this case, we
get that MAX-E3-SAT
is one minus one half divided
by seven, which is 1/14.
Technically there's
a minus epsilon here.
Sorry, bad overuse of epsilon.
This is, again, for any
epsilon greater than zero
because we had some epsilon
greater than zero here.
Slightly less than one
half is impossible.
So over here we get slightly
less than one minus 1/14
is impossible.
This is 13/14 minus
epsilon, which is OK.
It's a bound.
But it's not a tight bound.
The right answer
for MAX-3SAT is 7/8.
Because if you take, again,
a uniform random assignment,
every variable flips a coin,
heads or tails, true or false.
Then 7/8 of the clauses will
be satisfied in expectation.
Because if you look at a clause,
if it has exactly three terms
and it's an or of three things,
you just need at least one head
to satisfy this thing.
So you get a 50% chance to
do it in the first time,
and then a quarter chance
to do it in the third time,
and in general 7/8 chance to
get it one of the three times.
7/8 is smaller than 13/14,
so we're not quite there yet.
But this reduction
will do it if we
think about it from
the perspective
of gap-preserving reductions.
So from this general
L-reduction black box
that we only lose an alpha beta
factor, yeah we get this bound.
But from a gap perspective,
we can do better.
The reason we can do better
is because gaps are always
talking about yes instances
where lots of things
are satisfied.
That means we're most of the
time in the case where we have
fours on the right hand side, or
a situation where we have lots
of things unsatisfied, that
means we have lots of threes
on the right hand side.
It lets us get a
slightly tighter bound.
So let's do that.
So here is a gap argument
about the same reduction.
What we're going to claim is
that 7/8 minus epsilon gap 3SAT
is NP-hard, which implies
7/8 inapproximability,
but by looking at it
from the gap perspective,
we will get this stronger
bound versus the 13/14 bound.
So the proof is by a
gap-preserving reduction,
namely that reduction, from
MAX-E3-XNOR-SAT to MAX-3SAT,
E3-SAT I should say.
And so the idea
is the following.
Either we have a yes
instance or a no instance.
If we have a yes instance
to the equation problem,
then we know that at least one
minus epsilon of the equations
are satisfiable.
So we have one minus epsilon.
Let's say m is the
number of equations.
In the no instance
case, of course
we know that not too
many are satisfied.
At most, one half plus epsilon
fraction of the equations
are satisfiable.
So in both cases, I want to
see what that converts into.
So in the yes instance,
we get all four
of those things being satisfied.
So that means we're going
to have at least one
minus epsilon times m times
four clauses satisfied.
We'll also have
epsilon m times three.
Those are the unsatisfied.
And maybe some of them
are actually satisfied,
but this is a lower bound
on how many clauses we get.
On the other hand,
in this situation
where not too many
are satisfied,
that means we get a
tighter upper bound.
So we have one half plus
epsilon times m times four.
And then there's the rest, one
half minus epsilon times three.
And maybe some of these
are not satisfied,
but this is an upper bound on
how many clauses are satisfied
in the 3SAT instance versus
equations in the 3x [INAUDIBLE]
SAT instance.
Now I just want
to compute these.
So everything's times m.
And over here we have
four minus four epsilon.
Over here we have
plus three epsilon.
So that is four minus epsilon m.
And here we have again
everything is times m.
So we have 4/2, also known
as two, plus four epsilon.
Plus we have 3/2
minus three epsilon.
So the epsilons add
up to plus epsilon.
Then I check and see.
Four epsilon minus
three epsilon.
And then we have 4/2 plus
3/2, also known as 7/2.
Yes.
So we had a gap before, and
we get this new gap after.
When we have a yes
instance, we know
that there will be at
least this many clauses
satisfied in the 3SAT.
And there'll be at most this
many in the no instance.
So what we proved is
this bound that-- sorry,
get them in the right order.
7/2 is the smaller one.
7/2 plus epsilon, comma
four minus epsilon gap 3SAT,
E3-SAT, is NP-hard.
Because we had NP hardness
of the gap before,
we did this
gap-preserving reduction,
which ended up
with this new gap,
with this being for no
instances, this being
for yes instances.
And so if we want to-- this
is with the comma notation
for the yes and no what
fraction is satisfied.
If you convert it back
into the c gap notation,
you just take the ratio
between these two things.
And ignoring the epsilons,
this is like 4 divided by 7/2.
So that is 7/8 or 8/7, depending
on which way you're looking.
So we get also 7/8 gap.
Sorry, I guess it's 8/7 the
way I was phrasing it before.
It's also NP-hard.
And so that proves-- there's
also a minus epsilon.
So I should have kept those.
Slightly different epsilon, but
minus two epsilon, whatever.
And so this gives us the 8/7
is the best approximation
factor we can hope for.
AUDIENCE: In the
first notation, isn't
it the fraction of clauses?
So between zero and one?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Four is a little funny.
Right.
I needed to scale-- thank you--
because the number of clauses
in the resulting thing
is actually 4m, not m.
So everything here needs
to be divided by four.
It won't affect the final
ratio, but this should really
be over four and over four.
So also known as
7/8 plus epsilon,
comma one minus epsilon.
Now it's a little clearer, 7/8.
Cool.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So are there any
[INAUDIBLE] randomness?
AUDIENCE: So for [INAUDIBLE],
you can be the randomness.
Randomness would
give you one half.
[INAUDIBLE] algorithm
gives you 1.8.
PROFESSOR: So you can beat
it by a constant factor.
Probably not by more
than a constant factor.
MAX CUT is an example
where you can beat it.
I think I have the Goemans
Williamson bound here.
MAX CUT, the best
approximation is
0.878, which is better than
what you get by random,
which is a half I guess.
Cool.
All right.
So we get optimal
bound for MAX-E3-SAT,
assuming an optimum bound for
E3-XNOR-SAT, which is from PCP.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm sorry, can
you explain to me again why
we don't get this
from the L-reduction,
but we do get it from
the gap argument,
even though the reduction
is the same reduction?
PROFESSOR: It just lets
us give a tighter argument
in this case.
By thinking about yes instances
and no instances separately,
we get one thing.
Because this reduction is
designed to do different things
for yes and no instances.
Whereas the L-reduction
just says generically,
if you satisfy these
parameters alpha and beta,
you get some inapproximability
result on the output,
but it's conservative.
It's a conservative bound.
If you just use properties
one and two up here,
that's the best you could show.
But by essentially
reanalyzing property one,
but thinking separately
about yes and no instances--
this held for all instances.
We got a bound of seven.
But in the yes and
the no cases, you
can essentially get a
slightly tighter constant.
All right.
I want to tell you about
another cool problem.
Another gap hardness that you
can get out of PCP analysis
by some gap amplification
essentially, which
is called label cover.
So this problem takes a
little bit of time to define.
But the basic point is there
are very strong lower bounds
on the approximation factor.
So you're given a bipartite
graph, no weights.
The bipartition is A,
B. And furthermore, A
can be divided into k chunks.
And so can B. And these
are disjoint unions.
And let's say size of
A is n, size of B is n,
and size of each Ai
is also the same.
We don't have to make these
assumptions, but you can.
So let's make it a
little bit cleaner.
So in general, A consists of k
groups, each of size n over k.
B consists of k groups,
each of size n over k.
So that's our-- we have A
here with these little groups.
We have B, these little groups.
And there's some
edges between them.
In general, your goal is
to choose some subset of A,
let's call it A prime, and some
subset of B, call it B prime.
And one other thing
I want to talk about
is called a super edge.
And then I'll say what we
want out of these subsets
that we choose.
Imagine contracting
each of these groups.
There are n over k
items here, and there
are k different groups.
Imagine contracting each
group to a single vertex.
This is A1.
This is B3.
I want to say that there's
a super edge from the group
A1 to the group
B3 because there's
at least one edge between them.
If I squashed A1
to a single vertex,
B3 down to a single vertex, I
would get an edge between them.
So a super edge, Ai Bi--
Ai Bj, I should say--
exists if there's
at least one edge
in AI cross Bj, at least one
edge connecting those groups.
And I'm going to call such a
super edge covered by A prime B
prime if at least one of those
edges is in this chosen set.
So if there's at least
one edge-- sorry.
If this Ai cross Bj, these
are all the possible edges
between those groups, intersects
A prime cross B prime.
And in general, I want to cover
all the hyper edges if I can.
So I would like to
have a solution where,
if there is some edge
between A1 and B3,
then in the set of
vertices I choose,
A prime and B prime in the left,
they induce at least one edge
from A1 to B3, and
also from A2 to B3
because there is an
edge that I drew here.
I want ideally to choose
the endpoints of that edge,
or some other edge that
connects those two groups.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you're choosing
subsets A prime of A.
Is there some restriction
on the subset you choose?
Why don't you choose all of A?
PROFESSOR: Wait.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
You're not done yet?
PROFESSOR: Nope.
That's about half
of the definition.
it's a lot to say it's not
that complicated of a problem.
So there's two versions.
That's part of what
makes it longer.
We'll start with the
maximization version,
which is called Max-Rep.
So we have two constraints
on A prime and B prime.
First is that we choose exactly
one vertex from each group.
So we got A prime
intersect Ai equals
one, and B prime intersect Bj
equals one, for all i and j.
OK And then subject
to that constraint,
we want to maximize the
number of covered super edges.
Intuition here is that
those groups are labels.
And there's really one
super vertex there,
and you want to choose
one of those labels
to satisfy the instance.
So here you're only allowed to
choose one label per vertex.
We choose one out of
each of the groups.
Then you'd like to cover
as many edges as you can.
If there is an edge in the
super graph from Ai to Bj,
you would like to
include an induced edge.
There should actually be
an edge between the label
you assign to Ai and the
label you assign to Bj.
That's this version.
The complementary problem
is a minimization problem
where we switch what is relaxed,
what constraint is relaxed,
and what constraint must hold.
So here we're going to
allow multiple labels
for each super vertex,
multiple vertices
to be chosen from each group.
Instead we force that
everything is covered.
We want to cover every
super edge that exists.
And our goal is to minimize
the size of these sets,
A prime plus B prime.
So this is sort of
the dual problem.
Here we force one
level per vertex.
We want to maximize the
number of covered things.
Here we force everything
to be covered.
We want to essentially minimize
the number of labels we assign.
So these problems
are both very hard.
This should build you
some more intuition.
Let me show you a puzzle
which is basically
exactly this game, designed by
MIT professor Dana Moshkovitz.
So here's a word puzzle.
Your goal is to put letters
into each of these boxes-- this
is B, and this is A-- such
that-- for example, this
is animal, which means
these three things pointed
by the red arrows, those
letters should concatenate
to form an animal, like cat.
Bat is the example.
So if I write B, A, and T,
animal is satisfied perfectly.
Because all three
letters form a word,
I get three points so far.
Next let's think
about transportation.
For example, cab is
a three-letter word
that is transportation.
Notice there's always
three over here.
This corresponds to some
regularity constraint
on the bipartite graph.
There's always going to be three
arrows going from left to right
for every group.
So transportation, fine.
We got C-A-B. That is happy.
We happen to reuse the A,
so we get three more points,
total of six.
Furniture, we have
B, blank, and T left.
This is going to
be a little harder.
I don't know of any
furniture that starts with B
and ends with T and
is three letters long.
But if you, for example,
write an E here,
that's pretty close to the
word bed, which is furniture.
So in general, of course,
each of these words
corresponds to a set
of English words.
That's going to be the
groups on the left.
So this Ai group
for furniture is
the set of all words that are
furniture and three letters
long.
And then for each such
choice on the left,
for each such
choice on the right,
you can say is,
are they compatible
by either putting
an edge or not.
And so this is-- we got two
out of three of these edges.
These two are satisfied.
This one's not.
So we get two more points
for a total of eight.
This is for the
maximization problem.
Minimization would be different.
Here's a verb, where we
almost get cry, C-B-Y.
So we get two more points.
Here is another.
We want a verb.
Blank, A, Y. There are
multiple such verbs.
You can think of them.
And on the other hand,
we have a food, which
is supposed to be blank, E,
Y. So a pretty good choice
would be P for that top letter.
Then you get pay exactly
and almost get pea.
So a total score of 15.
And so this would be a
solution to Max-Rep of cost 15.
It's not the best.
And if you stare at this
example long enough,
you can actually get a perfect
solution of score 18, where
there are no violations.
Basically, in particular you do
say here and get soy for food.
AUDIENCE: So the sets on
the right are 26 letters?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The Bis here are the
alphabet A through Z,
and the sets on the
left are a set of words.
And then you're going to
connect two of them by an edge
if that letter happens to
match on the right, [INAUDIBLE]
letter.
So it's a little--
I mean, the mapping
is slightly complicated.
But this is a particular
instance of Max-Rep.
So what-- well, we get
some super extreme hardness
for these problems.
So let's start with epsilon,
comma one gap Max-Rep
is NP-hard.
So what I mean by this
is in the best situation,
you cover all of
the super edges.
So the one means 100% of
the super edges are covered.
Epsilon means that at most
an epsilon fraction of them
are covered.
So that problem is NP-hard.
This is a bit stronger
than what we had before.
Before we had a particular
constant, comma one or one
minus epsilon or something.
Here, for any constant
epsilon, this is true.
And there's a similar
result for Min-Rep.
It's just from one
to one over epsilon.
So this means there is no
constant factor approximation.
Max-Rep is not in APX.
But it's worse than that.
We need to assume slightly more.
In general, what you can show,
if you have some constant, p,
or there is a constant p, such
that if you can solve this gap
problem, one over p to the k,
so very tiny fraction of things
satisfied versus all
of the super edges
covered, then NP can be solved
in n to the order k time.
So we haven't usually
used this class.
Usually we talk about p, which
is the union of all these
for constant k.
But here k doesn't
have to be a constant.
It could be some function of n.
And in particular, if
p does not equal NP,
then k constant is not possible.
So this result
implies this result.
But if we let k get bigger
than a constant, like log-log n
or something, then we get
some separation between-- we
get a somewhat weaker
statement here.
We know if p does
not equal NP, we know
that NP is not contained in p.
But if we furthermore
assume that NP doesn't
have subexponential solutions,
and very subexponential
solutions, then we
get various gap bounds
inapproximability on Max-Rep.
So a reasonable
limit, for example,
is that-- let's say we assume
NP is not in n to the polylog n.
n to the polylog n is usually
called quasi-polynomial.
It's almost polynomial.
Log n is kind of close
to constant-- ish.
This is the same as two to the
polylog n, n to the polylog n.
But it's a little clearer.
This is obviously close
to polynomial, quite far
from exponential, which is
two to the n, not polylog.
So very different
from exponential.
So almost everyone
believes NP does not admit
quasi-polynomial solutions.
All problems in NP would
have to admit that.
3SAT, for example,
people don't think
you can do better than
some constant to the n.
Then what do we get when
we plug in that value of k?
That there is a no 1/2 to the
log to the one minus epsilon
n approximation.
Or also, the same
thing, gap is hard.
Now, it's not NP-hard.
But it's as hard
as this problem.
If you believe this is
not true, then there
will be no polynomial
time algorithm
to solve this
factor gap Max-Rep.
So this is very large.
We've seen this before in
this table of various results.
Near the bottom, there is a
lower bound of two to the log
to one minus epsilon n.
This is not assuming
p does not equal NP.
It's assuming this
statement, NP does not
have quasi-polynomial
algorithms.
And you see here
our friends Max-Rep
and Min-Rep, two
versions of label cover.
So I'm not going to
prove these theorems.
But again, they're
PCP style arguments
with some gap boosting.
But I would say most or a
lot of approximation lower
bounds in s world today
start from Max-Rep or Min-Rep
and reduce to the problem
using usually some kind
of gap-preserving reduction.
Maybe they lose the gap,
but we have such a huge gap
to start with that
even if you lose gap,
you still get
pretty good results.
So a couple of quick
examples here on the slides.
Directed Steiner forest.
Remember, you have
a directed graph,
and you have a bunch
of terminal pairs.
And you want to, in particular,
connect via directed path
some Ais and Bjs, let's say.
And you want to do so by
choosing the fewest vertices
in this graph.
So what I'm going to do, if I'm
given my bipartite graph here
for Min-Rep, I'm
just going to add--
to represent that
this is a group,
I'm going to add a vertex here
connect by directed edges here.
And there's a group
down here, so I'm
going to have downward
edges down there.
And whenever there's a
super edge from, say,
A2, capital A2 to
capital B1, then
I'm going to say in my directed
Steiner forest problem,
I want a path from
little a2 to little b1.
So in general, whenever
there's a super edge,
I add that constraint.
And then any solution to
directed Steiner forest
will exactly be a
solution to Min-Rep.
You're just forcing the
addition of the Ais and Bis.
It's again an L-reduction.
You're just offsetting by
a fixed additive amount.
So your gap OPT
will be the same.
And so you get that this problem
is just as hard as Min-Rep.
Well, this is another
one from set cover.
You can also show node
weighted Steiner trees.
Log n hard to approximate.
That's not from Min-Rep,
but threw it in there
while we're on the
topic of Steiner trees.
All right.
I want to mention one
more thing quickly
in my zero minutes remaining.
And that is unique games.
So unique games is a
special case of, say,
Max-Rep, or either label cover
problem, where the edges in Ai
cross Bj form a matching.
For every choice in
the left, there's
a unique choice on the right
and vice versa that matches.
Well, there's at most
one choice, I guess.
And I think that
corresponds to these games.
Once you choose
a word over here,
there's unique
letter that matches.
The reverse is not true.
So in this problem,
it's more like a star,
left to right star.
Once you choose this
word, it's fixed
what you have to choose
on the right side.
But if you choose a
single letter over here,
it does not uniquely
determine the word over here.
So unique games is
quite a bit stronger.
You choose either side,
it forces the other one,
if you want to cover that edge.
OK So far so good.
Unique games conjecture is that
the special case is also hard.
epsilon one minus epsilon gap
unique game is NP-hard.
Of course, there
are weaker versions
of this conjecture
that don't say NP-hard,
maybe assuming some weaker
assumption that there's
no polynomial time algorithm.
Unlike every other complexity
theoretic assumption
I have mentioned in
this class, this one
is the subject of much debate.
Not everyone believes
that it's true.
Some people believe
that it's false.
Many people believe--
basically people don't know
is the short answer.
There's some somewhat scary
evidence that it's not true.
There's slightly stronger forms
of this that are definitely not
true, which I won't get into.
There is a subexponential
algorithm for this problem.
But it's still up in the air.
A lot of people like to
assume that this is true
because it makes life
a lot more beautiful,
especially from an
inapproximability standpoint.
So for example, MAX-2SAT, the
best approximation algorithm is
0.940.
If you assume that
unique games, you
can prove a matching
lower bound.
That was MAX-2SAT for
MAX-CUT, as was mentioned,
0.878 is the best upper
bound by Goemans Williamson.
If you assume unique games,
then that's also tight.
There's a matching
this minus epsilon
or plus epsilon
inapproximability result.
And vertex cover, two.
You probably know how to do two.
If you assume unique games,
two is the right answer.
If you don't assume
anything, the best
we know how to prove
using all of this stuff
is 0.857 versus 0.5.
So it's nice to assume
unique games is true.
Very cool results is if you look
at over all the different CSP
problems that we've seen,
all the MAX-CSP problems,
and you try to solve it
using a particular kind
of semi-definite programming,
there's an STP relaxation.
If you don't know STPs,
ignore this sentence.
There's an STP relaxation
of all CSP problems.
You do the obvious thing.
And that STP will have
an integrality gap.
And if you believe
unique games conjecture,
then that integrality gap equals
the approximability factor,
one for one.
And so in this sense, if
you're trying to solve any CSP
problem, semi-definite
programming
is the ultimate tool for all
approximation algorithms.
Because if there's
a gap in the STP,
you can prove an
inapproximability result
of that minus epsilon.
So this is amazingly powerful.
The only catch is, we don't
know whether unique games
conjecture is true.
And for that reason, I'm not
going to spend more time on it.
But this gives you a flavor of
this side of the field, the gap
preservation approximation.
Any final questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If there's a
[INAUDIBLE] algorithm
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's
fine for a problem
to be slightly subexponential.
It's like two to the n to
the epsilon or something.
So when you do an
NP reduction, you
can blow things up by
a polynomial factor.
And so that n to the
epsilon becomes n again.
So if you start
from 3SAT where we
don't believe there's a
subexponential thing, when you
reduce to this, you
might end up putting it--
you lose that polynomial factor.
And so it's not a contradiction.
A bit subtle.
Cool.
See you Thursday.